Hi, everybody. Hi, guys. Hey, guys. I'm really proud of our show. Me too. Yeah. And we're going in a different direction now because we spent a better part of a year screwing around. Yeah, just making laughs, just building smiles and stuff.
大家好。大家好。嘿，各位。我真的为我们的节目感到骄傲。我也是。对。而我们现在要走向一个不同的方向，因为我们花了大半年的时间在胡闹。对，就是搞笑，博取大家的微笑之类的。
But I think our listeners deserve something a little bit better. They deserve us to be real. So the whole episode is going to kind of be like that. It can't just be jokes all the time. No, we can't tell jokes all the time. Just pull their car over to the side right now and just get real. Yeah. Just put it in park.
但我认为我们的听众值得拥有更好一点的东西。他们值得我们展现真实的一面。所以整集节目基本上都会是这种风格。不能总是只有笑话。对，我们不能总是讲笑话。现在就把他们的车停在路边，然后展现真实自我。对。就挂入P挡。
And I want you to grab the person next to you, wherever they are. Grab them by the shoulders and square them up and look them in the eye and just say, I respect you. I think the world of you, but it's time for me to listen to smartness. Here come smartness. You know? Yeah. Smart.
我希望你们抓住身边的任何人，无论他们在哪里。抓住他们的双肩，让他们转过身来，直视他们的双眼，然后对他们说：“我尊重你。我对你赞赏有加，但现在是我倾听智慧的时候了。智慧来咯。”你知道吗？对。智慧。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
智慧。智慧。智慧。智慧。智慧。智慧。智慧。智慧。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Look, I've been I've been notified. First of all. I just want to say before we start with our guest that I was listening back to the interview
智慧。智慧。智慧。智慧。智慧。听着，我被……我被通知了。首先。在我们的嘉宾到来之前，我只想说，我回听了那次采访
with Sean Penn and I heard a lot of listener feedback that I asked potentially the longest question in the history of smartness and I people like people really gave it to me. Guarantee that. Yep. I haven't finished that interview, listening to it, because. Because of the question. You haven't finished the question. Oh, so worn out with your, God.
采访肖恩·潘（Sean Penn），我听到很多听众反馈说，我问了可能是“聪明人”节目历史上最长的一个问题，人们真的把我说了一通。我敢保证。是的。我还没听完那次采访，因为……因为那个问题。你还没听完那个问题。哦，对你的问题厌烦透顶了，天哪。
But also people were saying like, you know, you give Bateman a lot of shit for the long question, then you have one. And my answer to that is fuck off. Yeah, I love that answer. You know, because then there's no. Remember what I said earlier, but you've been sunny all the time.
但大家也说，你知道的，你因为那个长问题把贝特曼骂得狗血淋头，结果你自己也来了一个。而我的回答是：滚蛋。对，我喜欢这个回答。你知道的，因为那就没有……还记得我刚才说的吗，但你最近一直阴阳怪气的。
I know. I've been really prickly lately. That's so nice. Everybody looks really awake today. Yeah. It's 20 minutes later than it used to be. Wow. Well, you're about to get into it with our guests then,
我知道。我最近真的很扎人。太好了。每个人今天看起来都很清醒。 yeah。比平时晚了20分钟。哇。那你们接下来就要和我们的嘉宾好好聊聊了，
because our guest is somebody who you do not want to tangle with. Oh, wait, crap. Let me finish. Let me just say that our guests, and I know that you review our guests and have a lot of respect for them. So this is going to be really interesting
因为我们的嘉宾是你绝对不想招惹的人。哦，等等，糟了。让我说完。我只想说我们的嘉宾，我知道你对我们的嘉宾做过功课，而且非常尊重他们。所以这将会非常有趣，
to see you dig your way out. I know that because we've talked about him many times over the years. He's somebody who's a sort of like a, I don't know how you'd say it, like a cultural icon. Like Tyson. Hold on.
看你怎么给自己解围。我知道这一点，因为我们这些年来多次谈论过他。他是一个某种程度上的人，我不知道你该怎么形容，就像一个文化偶像。就像泰森。等等。
Somebody who I've always looked up to comedically, but also somebody who I've always looked up to for, I think that he lends on the right side of a lot of things, which is he just applies a lot of what we like to call logic to issues. And he ended up informing people in a way through his comedy show. He really informed, gave people a lot
一个我在喜剧方面一直仰慕的人，但也是一个我在很多事情上一直仰慕的人，因为我认为他在很多事情上都站在正确的一边，也就是说他只是把许多我们喜欢称之为“逻辑”的东西应用到问题中。他最终以一种通过他的喜剧节目的方式来告知人们。他真正地告知了人们、给予了人们很多
of real world information and education that they probably didn't know that they were gonna, they thought they were just signing up for a comedy program. And they actually got to learn. He's a clearly a very thoughtful guy. I don't wanna, you know, belabor it too long just to say that he's somebody that I'm really, really honored that he's here.
现实世界的资讯和教育，而他们可能并不知道自己会……他们以为自己只是报名了一个喜剧节目。但他们实际上学到了东西。他显然是一个非常深思熟虑的人。我不想，你知道的，喋喋不休太久，只想说他是那种我真的、真的非常荣幸他能来到这里的人。
And I just think he's, and I don't really know him. We've met a handful of times. I was gonna be serious. Without further ado, Mr. John Stewart. Mr. Good Lord. Look at the reveal. It was incredible.
我觉得他……而且我其实不太了解他。我们见过几次面。我本来想严肃一点的。废话少说，有请乔恩·斯图尔特（John Stewart）先生。天哪。看看这个亮相。太不可思议了。
And he's got a mask in his hand. Wait a minute. Did you have a mask over the camera? I respected him until that. And then that just destroyed. I put it on my computer to make sure that the computer doesn't get the virus. Here we go.
他手里还拿着一个面具。等一下。你刚才把面具罩在摄像头上了吗？在此之前我都挺尊重他的。然后那个举动直接把我好感全无了。我把它戴在我的电脑上，是为了确保电脑不会感染病毒。我们开始吧。
John, this is... Are you upset? Jason, I was late. Can I tell you why I was late? Cause I could tell it upset you a little bit, Jason. You were trying to get rid of the sound quality in your room. I was working at an orphanage.
乔恩，这是……你生气了吗？杰森，我迟到了。我能告诉你我为什么迟到吗？因为我看得出来这让你有点心烦，杰森。你当时正试图消除你房间里的音质。我刚才在孤儿院做义工。
No. Oh, Jesus. Let me see a kid. Show me one kid right now. Can I ask you a question? And I don't, I don't podcast much, so I don't know. Sure. There's plenty of room in the space.
不。噢，天哪。让我看看小孩。现在就给我看一个小孩。我能问你个问题吗？我不……我不怎么做播客，所以我不太了解。当然。这里空间很大。
Has Will been kidnapped? Yeah. Yeah, Will's in a dark room. I'm in a cloth, I'm in a cloth booth inside the middle of a larger room that also has no furniture in it. So it's very... Hey, listener, John Stewart doesn't hand out
威尔被绑架了吗？对。对，威尔在一个黑漆漆的房间里。我在一个布制的小隔间里，在一个更大的房间正中间，那个房间里也没有家具。所以非常……嘿，听众朋友们，乔恩·斯图尔特可不怎么接受
a bunch of interviews. He doesn't do this a lot. So I'm very... Long time. Honored and this is very nice of you to do this. Very thrilling. Yeah. Very thrilling.
大量的采访。他不常这么做。所以我非常……好久不见。感到荣幸，你能做客这里真是太好了。非常令人兴奋。是的。非常令人兴奋。
I'm delighted. They told me, you know, you've got to do some promotion for this. What are you promoting? A show on Apple. And they gave me a list of podcasts and yours was the only one on it. Wow.
我很高兴。他们告诉我，你知道的，你得为这个做些宣传。你在宣传什么？苹果公司的一个节目。他们给了我一个播客名单，而你们的是唯一的。哇。
A list of one? A list of one. No, I was excited to come and talk to you guys because you're three very funny, nice, lovely gentlemen. You're a nice man. Back at ya. Well, thank you. We were gonna get to the Apple show,
唯一的名单？唯一的名单。不，我很高兴来和你们聊聊，因为你们是三个非常有趣、友善、可爱的绅士。你是个好人。彼此彼此。谢谢。我们本来要聊聊苹果的那个节目，
but let's talk about it right off the bat. Just a little bit about what's going on with that. Oh, that I don't know. I mean, I'm here to talk about whatever... Yeah, what is the show? Just tell me what it's called and when it's on because I'm gonna be first in line. It's been too long.
但我们开门见山吧。稍微聊聊那个节目进展如何。哦，那个我不知道。我是说，我来这是为了聊任何……对，那是什么节目？只要告诉我它叫什么名字，什么时候播出就行，因为我绝对会冲在第一个。太久没看到了。
It's on Apple, but to be honest with you, I don't know how to access it. Sure. John, by the way, if it's on Apple, Jason means that he'll be first in line because he will have been halfway back the line and then he'll cut the line. I don't know if you've seen...
它在苹果上，但老实说，我不知道怎么看。当然。乔恩，顺便说一句，如果它在苹果上，杰森的意思是他会冲在第一个，因为他会先排到队伍的一半，然后插队。我不知道你有没有看过……
No, I didn't realize that. You can look that up. Yeah, when the iPhones first came out, Jason cut the line famously. No. Does he big foot the people? Dude, can I just tell you that? I don't know if I've told this story before on our podcast,
不，我没意识到。你可以去查查。对，当年iPhone刚出来的时候，杰森大肆插队。没有。他会把别人挤走吗？老兄，我能说这个吗？我不知道我以前在我们的播客里有没有讲过这个故事，
but when the first iPod came out, iPhone, Jason said, oh, you're gonna get like a special hookup and get the phone early. I said, yeah, I'm gonna stay. Somebody's gonna send it to me. And yes, of course. He goes, well, I'm gonna go wait in line like everybody else.
但当第一代iPod出来时，不，iPhone，杰森说，哦，你会拿到那种特殊的内部渠道，提前拿到手机。我说，对，我会留着的。会有人寄给我的。然后，当然。他说，好吧，我要像其他人一样去排队。
I said, great. So Bateman goes to the... He's on with the people. So he goes down to the Grove and he's trying a big time telling me that he's with the people. He goes to the Grove. I'm standing in line like Star Wars movies. Like a Star Wars movie.
我说，太好了。于是贝特曼就去了……他和大家在一起。所以他去了格罗夫购物中心（The Grove），他摆出大人物的架子，告诉我他和大家在一起。他去了格罗夫。我就像看《星球大战》电影一样排着队。就像《星球大战》电影一样。
To his credit, he's there like 150th in line. Somebody, an employee at the Apple store in the Grove sees him, goes up and says, Mr. Bateman, just please come this way. And he goes with him. Of course, the paparazzi get photos of him jumping the line and he ends up getting more shit for that. For jumping the line.
平心而论，他大概排在第150位。格罗夫苹果店的一个员工看到他，走过去说：“贝特曼先生，请走这边。”然后他就跟他走了。当然，狗仔队拍到了他插队的照片，结果他为此挨了不少骂。因为插队。
For jumping the line. Being a man of the people and jumping the line. Couldn't have been more beautiful. And when I called the paparazzi and told him to go get it. And apparently a year later, when I think it was Tim Cook, was at a meeting of the folks who were in charge of all this stuff, he literally said to them,
因为插队。作为一个平民却插队。简直不能再精彩了。当我打电话给狗仔队让他们去拍的时候。显然一年后，我想当时是蒂姆·库克（Tim Cook），在一次负责所有这些事务的人员会议上，他真的对他们说：
let's make sure our VIPs get their phones ahead of time. Let's not pull another Bateman this year. It's actually named after you. It was a very embarrassing. John, tell me about this Apple show. Is it a standup? Is it a scripted show? Is it something you're directing?
“一定要确保我们的VIP提前拿到手机。今年可别再搞出什么‘贝特曼事件’了。”这实际上是以你的名字命名的。那是一次非常尴尬的……乔恩，跟我讲讲这个苹果节目吧。是单口喜剧吗？是有剧本的节目吗？是你导演的节目吗？
You're in? It's not a standup show and it's not a scripted show. It's more of a kind of combining some of the things I learned on the Daily Show with some of the things I learned from being down in Washington. Sort of the ethos of it is kind of that, why are really obvious problems that have solutions? Why don't they get addressed and fixed?
你参演了吗？这不是单口喜剧，也不是有剧本的节目。它更像是把我在《每日秀》（The Daily Show）学到的一些东西，与我在华盛顿学到的一些东西结合起来。它的精神内核有点像是，为什么那些有着显而易见解决方案的明显问题，为什么它们得不到解决和纠正？
And it's kind of the ethos of it. We're not doing that many of them. John, the description of that show, you are filling a surprisingly huge hole in media right now. Like, that's an obvious thing that I just shocked that no one's addressed yet, or maybe no one's as smart or as savvy as you. Well, watch the show.
这有点像是它的精神内核。我们不会做那么多期。乔恩，对那个节目描述，你目前正在填补媒体中一个令人惊讶的巨大空白。就像，这是一个显而易见的事情，我简直震惊居然还没人处理过，或者也许没有人像你一样聪明或精明。好吧，看节目吧。
You'll see we don't actually get anything done. But my God, there seems to be so many obvious problems with obvious solutions that we just, we tie ourselves into knots trying to figure out why they're not being solved when you just, it's a big fat green button somebody needs to push and everything will be right. In the world.
你会发现我们其实什么都没干成。但是天哪，似乎有那么多显而易见的问题，却有着显而易见的解决方案，而我们只是作茧自缚，试图弄清楚为什么它们没有得到解决，而你只需要——这是一个需要有人按下的大红按钮，一切都会好起来的。在这个世界上。
Jason, I really wish you hadn't have given away the ending to my show. It's, you know, I mean, we step right into this thing and five minutes into it, you're like, it's a fucking green button. And I'm like, oh, that's great. Thanks. Thanks.
杰森，我真希望你没有剧透我的节目结局。你知道的，我的意思是，我们刚切入这个话题，五分钟不到，你就剧透了，说什么这是个该死的大红按钮。然后我就想，哦，太棒了。谢谢。谢谢。
You know what? I'm gonna blow season four of Ozark. How about that? How about I jump in? Turns out you guys all move out of Missouri and you fucking get your own boat. John, would it be safe to say that your show is kind of the crying game
你知道吗？我要剧透《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）第四季。怎么样？要不我直接剧透？结果原来你们全都搬出了密苏里州，然后各自去买了自己的船。乔恩，能不能这样说，你的节目有点像是苹果全新流媒体服务里的《哭泣游戏》
of the new Apple streaming service? I don't think there's any, I don't think there's any question about it. And now that it's been blown, it turns out we were all dead the whole time. There, are you happy now, Jason? We were all sleeping next to Suzanne Plachette. It was just one big dream.
我觉得毫无疑问就是这样。既然已经被剧透了，原来我们从头到尾都死掉了。好了，你现在高兴了吧，杰森？我们都睡在苏珊·普莱谢特（Suzanne Plachette）旁边。这只是一场大梦。
Oh, was that not the greatest? It was pretty, it was pretty good. So at the risk of doing another spoiler on, is it, does it, and to be slightly serious, does it all kind of boil down to ignoring the squeaky minority and listen to the quiet majority? I think what we find is, and it's almost like the laws of thermodynamics, you know,
哦，那难道不是最棒的吗？挺不错的，挺不错的。那么，冒着再次剧透的风险，它是不是……为了稍微严肃一点，它是不是最终都归结为忽略那个大呼小叫的少数派，而去倾听安静的大多数？我认为我们发现的是，这有点像热力学定律，你知道，
a body at rest has a tendency to stay at rest and a body in motion has a tendency to stay in motion. And I think the status quo generally stagnant and does not like to take risks or to put itself on the line when it may be held responsible for the consequences. And so what happens is there's a certain stagnation and there's a certain remove that,
静止的物体倾向于保持静止，运动的物体倾向于保持运动。我认为现状通常是停滞不前的，不喜欢承担风险，也不喜欢在可能要对后果负责时把自己置于风口浪尖。所以发生的事情是，存在着某种停滞，也存在着某种脱节，
the people generally in charge of things are at great remove from the people affected by things. And that when you permeate that kind of, that bubble that they are in, it's very difficult to get them. It stemmed from, you know, I remember going down on, this is, I mean, can I, is this, can I tell a heavier story?
通常掌权的人与受事物影响的人严重脱节。而当你渗透进那种他们身处的气泡时，要让他们改变是非常困难的。它源于，你知道，我记得去过……这是，我是说，我可以，这是一个……我能讲一个比较沉重的故事吗？
Of course, yeah, please do. Anything that starts with going down on. Yeah, you left off at going down on. So I'm blowing a veteran. It was a revelation from the 9-11 hearings and we were down there and, you know, these guys that had been on the pile for 9-11 and had suffered for really going on decades,
当然，可以，请讲。任何以“去过”开头的。对，你停在了“去过”。所以我正在给一个退伍老兵口交。这是9·11听证会上的一个爆料，我们当时在那里，你知道，这些参与了9·11残骸清理、并且遭受了简直长达数十年的痛苦的家伙们，
the health effects of toxic exposures and anybody who'd been down there knew, you know, they were told the air was safe, but I don't think things that smell like that are safe. Yeah, there's just some kind of statistic that it just came out this week about how many of them have passed away or are deathly ill.
有毒物质暴露带来的健康影响，任何去过那里的人都知道，你知道，他们被告知空气是安全的，但我不认为闻起来那种味道的东西是安全的。对，刚出炉的统计数据恰好就在本周公布，关于他们当中有多少人已经离世或病入膏肓。
It's just awful. Tragic. Yeah. So we went down to testify in front of Congress and we were there as a guy named John Field who runs the Field Good Foundation. And, you know, we've lost some people that we'd worked with Ray Pfeiffer,
简直太糟糕了。悲剧。对。所以我们去国会作证，我们在那里的一个人叫约翰·菲尔德（John Field），他运营着“美好基金会”（Field Good Foundation）。你知道，我们失去了一些曾共事过的人，比如雷·法伊弗（Ray Pfeiffer），
who was a firefighter that had come down and lobbied with us and this guy Lou Alvers, who's a cop. He had been in the armed forces and then he was on the bomb squad. He's just this unbelievable guy. He'd been through like 160 chemotherapies and you could, you see it all.
他是一名消防员，曾下来和我们一起游说，还有这个叫路·阿尔韦尔斯（Lou Alvers）的家伙，他是个警察。他曾在军队服役，后来加入了拆弹小组。他简直是个不可思议的家伙。他经历过大约160次化疗，你能看出来，这一切你都历历在目。
And we knew that we were losing Lou over the past six months to a year that we'd been advocating and bringing him down to DC. So we're down and Lou's to my right and we're sitting and we're in this room of Congress people, half of whom don't even show up to the hearing. It's like a hearing of like, I think the committee's like 18 Congress people.
我们知道在过去六个月到一年里，随着我们一直在倡导并将他带到华盛顿，我们正在失去路。所以我们到了那里，路在我的右边，我们坐着，我们在一个国会议员的房间里，其中有一半人甚至都没有出席听证会。这就像是一个听证会，我记得委员会大概有18个国会议员。
It was like seven that are there. Two of them, Louie Gohmert and Jim Jordan, who are, I think they're in the dumb ass coalition. I think that's the official title of what they're in. They come in, they sit for a minute, get counted as present and then take their name tags and leave. So they count as present.
当时到场的只有大约七个。其中两个，路易·戈默特（Louie Gohmert）和吉姆·乔丹（Jim Jordan），我认为他们属于“笨蛋联盟”。我想那是他们加入的组织的正式名称。他们进来坐了一分钟，被算作出席，然后拿走名牌就离开了。所以他们算作出席了。
So Lou gives his testimony and it's about, you know, I'm here because I don't ever want other people to go through what I've been through and I'm here to make sure that that doesn't happen. And it just, Lou felt there's something off. It just wasn't, you know, this guy is pretty stoic to begin with, but I could tell like that night is liver fails.
于是路发表了他的证词，大致意思是，我在这里是因为我永远不希望其他人经历我所经历的事情，我来这里是为了确保这种事情不再发生。只是，路觉得有些不对劲。情况并非如此，你知道的，这家伙本来就挺坚忍的，但我能看出那天他的肝功能衰竭了。
He goes into hospice. That night, literally on the way back from Washington, right? So I'm furious. I rip into the Congress people for their inattention for their, you know, these guys answered the call five seconds after 9-11. It's been fucking 18 years. What are you doing?
他进了临终关怀病房。就在那天，字面意思，在从华盛顿回来的路上，对吧？所以我气疯了。我痛斥国会议员们的漫不经心，痛斥他们，你知道的，这些人在9·11发生后五秒钟就挺身而出了。这他妈都18年了。你们在干什么？
One of the Congress people, and I was complaining about how there was nobody there in the room that's like seven Congress people. It's just, it's a metaphor for the way that we ignore. They all hold them up as heroes. Never forget the heroes of 9-11. Here these guys are, and nobody's in the fucking room. All right.
其中一个国会议员——我当时在抱怨房间里怎么一个人都没有，只有大约七个国会议员。这简直是我们忽视问题的一种隐喻。他们把这些人奉为英雄。永不忘记9·11的英雄。而这些家伙就在这里，结果他妈的房间里一个人也没有。好吧。
So the head of the committee, I think his name is Elliot Cohen. He's a Congressman Democrat. He says to me, look, I understand you're upset, but please know like we're very busy. Yeah. And I was like that right there crystallized for me what the issue was.
所以委员会的负责人，我想他叫埃利奥特·科恩（Elliot Cohen）。他是一名民主党国会议员。他对我说：“听着，我理解你很难过，但请知道，我们真的很忙。”对。而我当时就觉得，那一刻对我来说让问题变得无比清晰。
I'm sitting next to someone who has decided to spend his last moments on this earth advocating for those who are suffering from similar fates to his and trying to alleviate some of the consequences that they may face in the future if this doesn't get done. And this motherfucker is just like, I got 10 meetings today.
我正坐在一个人旁边，他决定把他在这个世上的最后时刻花在为那些遭受与他类似命运的人发声上，并试图减轻如果这件事办不成他们在未来可能面临的一些后果。而这个王八蛋却说：“我今天有10个会。”
Yeah. I mean, I mean, you can't expect me to go to all of them. And so I was, to me, that's the disconnect. It's rhetoric versus reality. It's those who are affected by things versus those that control them. And those dynamics, the daily show was like, it was like being a weatherman
对。我是说，我是说，你总不能指望我把每个会都去参加吧。所以对我来说，这就是脱节所在。这是辞令与现实的脱节。这是受影响的人与控制局面的人之间的脱节。而这些动态，《每日秀》就像是，就像是一个天气预报员，
for like the daily bullshit, right? I'm hoping that this show is kind of more of a climatologist view kind of a, how are these systems incentivized? Right. And how do we rearrange that? Not just an observation, but how the fuck did we get here?
播报日常的废话，对吧？我希望这个节目能更像是一个气候学家的视角，比如，这些系统是如何被激励的？对。以及我们如何重新安排它？不仅仅是观察，而是我们他妈的是怎么走到这一步的？
And I was going to kind of say, I was going to bring that back to, it seems very, to me anyway, to a layman such as myself, and I actually don't get laid that often, was that you started the daily show as a comedy show. It was kind of a Trojan horse, if you will, in that you, it was a hilarious, hilarious show. The only time I got to do it,
我本来想说的是，我想把话题带回，在我看来——至少对我这样一个外行来说，而且我其实不常过性生活——你创办《每日秀》时把它作为一个喜剧节目。它有点像是一匹特洛伊木马，如果你愿意这么说的话，因为它是一个极其爆笑的节目。我唯一一次能上节目的机会，
you weren't even hosting somebody else was, I had like Cordray or somebody else. No, that was in the contract. That was on purpose. That was something that... It felt very personal. It was before you'd ever been in show business and I had to put it in there.
甚至都不是你主持的，而是别人。我有科德里（Cordray）还是别的什么人。不，那是合同里写好的。那是故意的。那是……这感觉非常私人。那是在你进入演艺圈之前，我不得不把它写进去。
If someone in Will Arnett ever gets in this business, please. That's fucking foresight. And I, but I remember, it seems to me, you started doing that show and it became so much more relevant, not just comedically, but it also became very much part of the conversation because you can see the kind of,
如果威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）以后进入这一行，求求了。这他妈真有远见。而且，我记得，在我看来，你开始做那个节目时，它变得越来越具有相关性，不仅仅是在喜剧方面，它也深深地融入了对话中，因为你能看到那种……
you can see that the genesis of these things, as you railed against things comedically and the issues got more and more serious and you kind of dug deeper into it, kind of, there did feel like there was a point where you were like, come on, everybody, what the fuck is going on? And my question is, did you then sort of graduate
你能看到这些事情的起源，随着你在喜剧上对种种现象进行抨击，议题变得越来越严肃，而你又深入挖掘，确实感觉有那么一个时刻，你会觉得：“拜托，大家，这到底是怎么回事？”我的问题是，你后来是不是“毕业”了？
since you've left the daily show? Was there like a frustration threshold that you fucking burst through? You're like, I can't even joke about it anymore because this shit is so stupid. I gotta do something about it. And you people are acting like such fucking idiots. Was there a moment where you were just like,
自从你离开《每日秀》之后？是不是有一个沮丧的阈值被你他妈的突破了？你当时是不是觉得：“我甚至无法再拿它开玩笑了，因为这破事太蠢了。我得做点什么。”而你们这些人表现得像一群他妈的白痴。有没有那么一个瞬间，你当时就觉得：
God, I can't even, it's not even funny almost anymore. How long was the question that you asked that people gave you shit for? I know. How long was it? The Sheldon Payne question was a fucking embarrassment. It was an embarrassment.
天哪，我甚至……这几乎都快不好笑了。你问的那个让大家骂你的问题到底有多长？我知道。有多长？谢尔顿·佩恩（Sheldon Payne）的问题简直是个大写的尴尬。那是个尴尬。
But I will say that my question just now was what we call half abatement. Half abatement. Half abatement. No, it was half abatement. We get half abatement. I mean, I think it's, look, satire has always been a way of processing things
但我得说，我刚才问的那个问题，就是我们所说的“半个贝特曼”。半个贝特曼。半个贝特曼。不，那就是半个贝特曼。我们享受半个贝特曼。我是说，我认为，看，讽刺一直是处理那些
that mean a lot to you. So comedy has always been used to process things that, and it's always a continuum. The show is a recipe. Sometimes it was incredibly silly. Yeah, we did an episode on 9-11 first responders, but I also got a church choir to sing, go fuck yourself to a reporter on Fox News.
对你意义重大事情的一种方式。所以喜剧一直被用来处理那些……而且它一直是一个连续体。这个节目就像是一道食谱。有时它荒谬无比。对，我们做过一期关于9·11急救人员的节目，但我还找了一个教堂唱诗班，对着福克斯新闻（Fox News）的一个记者唱“去你妈的”。
Like, it's always that kind of, you know, it's, it's scatological and it's, but at the heart of it, satire really isn't, it's comedy about things you care deeply about. And that's always been the recipe. I think I probably just have gotten less elegant. And we will be right back. And now back to the show.
就像这样，你知道的，它既带有排泄物笑话的粗俗，但在它的核心，讽刺其实并非如此，它是关于那些你深切关怀之事的喜剧。而这一直都是秘方。我想我可能只是变得没那么优雅了。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。
You know, John, your daily help for those of us who are not as informed was so appreciated. Yes, agreed. And I'm sure incredibly effective. Agreed. It seems like we need not less of you, but more of you. It's to make it as rarefied as you can get it. I want to be the saffron of comedy.
你知道吗，乔恩，对于我们这些没那么见多识广的人来说，你的日常帮助真是感激不尽。是的，完全同意。我敢肯定其效果也极其显著。完全同意。看起来我们需要的不是减少你，而是需要更多的你。要把它做到尽可能精纯。我想成为喜剧界的藏红花。
John. Rich, little bit of flavor, put it into the sauce. It creates maybe a tinge of color, but you never want too much. We're at a multi-bell alert here. Is there any chance of, I mean, I know you've directed the movie or two, you've had a kid or four, you've relaxed, I'm sure.
乔恩。浓郁，带有一点风味，把它放进酱汁里。它可能会带来一丝色彩，但你永远不希望放太多。我们这里处于多重警报状态。有没有可能，我是说，我知道你导演过一两部电影，生过四五个孩子，你肯定也放松过了。
Can you get back on the stick and help us out? Oh, I've been on it, baby. And by the way, there's so much on it. We're also used to the idea of that form now. So it's, you know. It's a lot of it. It was time for me, as far as leaving the Daily Show, like I just, I didn't leave because I didn't care anymore.
你能重新振作起来帮帮我们吗？哦，我一直都在拼，宝贝。顺便说一句，这上面有太多东西了。我们现在也习惯了那种形式的概念。所以，你知道的。里面有很多。对我而言，就离开《每日秀》而言，我只是……我离开并不是因为我不在乎了。
I left because I couldn't think of another interesting way to evolve the show. And I would imagine you guys feel this too, is I don't feel public pressure. I feel the pressure from the people that I work with. Like when you're leading one of those shows, you owe it to them to try and kind of inspire them to come in with a certain amount of enthusiasm
我离开是因为我想不出另一种有趣的方式来演进这个节目。我想你们也有同感，我感受到的不是来自公众的压力，而是来自与我共事的伙伴们的压力。就像当你领导其中一个节目时，你亏欠他们的是，试着去激励他们，让他们带着某种热忱加入进来，
and a certain amount of directionality and a certain amount of, you know, leadership. Sure. So you don't feel like a weird responsibility because you're so good at what you do. And like we keep saying, you know, there hasn't been anybody like you, nor has there been. No, I think there's like 10 of them.
带着某种明确的方向感，以及带着某种，你知道的，领导力。当然。所以你不会觉得有一种奇怪的责任感吗？因为你太擅长你所做的事了。而且就像我们一直说的，你知道的，从来没有过像你这样的人，也从来没有过……不，我觉得大概有10个吧。
No, no. But what I'm saying is. I think we're in pretty good shape. But your ability to deliver the news and let the medicine go down easy is just incredibly valuable. But I wonder sometimes, if that's even a good thing, you know, I got to a certain point where, you know,
不，不。但我的意思是。我觉得我们状态还不错。但你传递新闻并让苦口良药易于下咽的能力，简直是极有价值的。但我有时在想，这甚至是一件好事吗？你知道的，我到了某个阶段，
if the medicine goes down so easy, maybe you don't even realize you need medicine. But if the only other option is that people simply won't even seek out the medicine, I'd rather it go down easy than them just keep their head in the sand and, you know, watch Judge Judy. We've also, by the way, she has been on fire.
如果良药太容易下咽，也许你根本意识不到自己需要吃药。但如果唯一的其他选择是人们甚至根本不去找药，我宁愿它容易下咽，也不愿他们继续把头埋在沙子里，你知道的，去看《朱迪法官》（Judge Judy）。顺便说一句，她最近状态火热。
Come on. On fire. Incredible talent. Can I tell you the other day, Judy, I watch her enough to just call her Judy. Sure. There was a woman, she was rebutting the gentleman. It was a rental issue.
拜托。火热。不可思议的天才。我能告诉你吗，前几天，朱迪——我经常看她的节目，所以直呼她朱迪。当然。有个女人，她在反驳那位男士。那是一个租房纠纷。
And Judy, just with a simple, didn't even finish the word don't. Just, duh, duh, duh, just different forms of the letter D. As long as you get the eyebrows up as high as possible, all you need is the D. At a certain point, didn't even hit the consonant. Duh! No, that's power.
而朱迪，仅仅用了一个简单的、甚至都没把“don't”这个词说完。就只是，“哒，哒，哒”，只是字母D的不同发音。只要你把眉毛尽量往上挑，你所需要的就只有这个D。在某个节点，甚至都没有发辅音。哒！不，这就是力量。
Shut it down, verdict for the plaintiff. That's ultimate power. That is studied and learned in like, yeah, no, I love Judge Judy to be clear. And I see you're all eating Chinese food all the, I used to anyway down around the corner. So here's the thing, you know, a lot of the times when you're on TV all the time
休庭，原告胜诉。那是终极权力。那是在诸如……对，为了澄清，我真的很喜欢《朱迪法官》。而且我看到你们一直在吃中餐，我以前在街角也经常去。所以情况是这样的，你知道的，很多时候当你整天都在电视上露面，
and people just assume that you live inside that box, right? In the world. And then when you, when years have gone and you haven't been inside the box, people are like, what happened? Where did you go? What are you doing? And it's like, what do you mean, what am I doing?
人们就会想当然地认为你生活那个小盒子里，对吧？在这个世界上。然后当岁月流逝，你不再身处那个盒子里时，人们就会问：发生什么了？你去哪儿了？你在干什么？这就好比是：什么意思，我能干什么？
I have a life outside of that box. But I fall into that same dumb category when you just came on the screen here right now. I was like, oh my God, John Stuart, I love John Stuart. And, but I fucking fell in that same thing. I'm like, where's John Stuart been? Now, I know you've been directing things and I know you've been around,
我在那个盒子之外还有生活。但当你在此时此刻出现在屏幕上时，我也陷入了那种愚蠢的类别。我当时就想：“天哪，乔恩·斯图尔特，我太爱乔恩·斯图尔特了。”但是，我他妈的也陷入了那种心态。我就想：“乔恩·斯图尔特去哪儿了？”现在，我知道你一直在导演东西，我也知道你一直都在，
but for those people, like myself, I was like, like Jason was saying, it's so important you're so missed in that arena that- Well, there's also a nostalgia around that to some extent. And I, listen, don't get me wrong, fellas. I appreciate this and it's very kind of you, but there is a nostalgia that grows around something that you remember more fondly than perhaps at the time.
但对于那些人，比如我自己，我就觉得——就像杰森刚才说的，你在这个领域里太重要了，太让人怀念了，以至于……好吧，某种程度上这也带着一层怀旧滤镜。而且，听着，别误会我，伙计们。我很感激，而且你们非常友善，但对于某些你记忆中比当时感觉更好的东西，总是会滋生出一种怀旧情绪。
And at the time we were inconsistent at times. We were controversial at times. I took my fair share of shit, not from you guys mostly, Jason, yes, but- And by the way, you're one of the best interviewers, maybe the best interviewer, full stop, you know, we can get into that later, but that was also awesome. Just as a guest and as a viewer.
而在当时，我们有时表现得并不稳定。我们有时也备受争议。我也承受了我应得的批评，虽然不是大多来自你们——杰森，是的，但是——顺便说一句，你是有史以来最好的采访者之一，也许就是最好的采访者，句号，你知道的，我们以后可以深入探讨这个，但那真的很棒。无论是作为嘉宾还是作为观众。
But there is a certain golden glow that nobody remembers you more fondly. But remember, there's also the reverse of that, which is nothing turns to disappointment and anger faster than love. And when people fall in love with a program or they fall in love with what you do. Yes, that's so true.
但其中确实存在着一种金色光芒，没有人会不带着更美好的回忆来看待你。但记住，这也有一体两面，那就是没有什么比爱更容易变成失望和愤怒了。当人们爱上一个节目，或者他们爱上你所做的事情时。没错，太对了。
There's, I mean, for God's sakes, they're going after Ted Lasso. Yeah, are they really? Oh yeah. Oh really? So I guess my point is I try really hard to insulate and isolate myself from external commentary. I really rely on a moral barometer that is developed
我的意思是，天哪，他们甚至开始攻击《泰德·拉索》（Ted Lasso）了。对，真的吗？哦，真的吗？所以我想说的是，我非常努力地将自己与外部评论隔离开来。我真正依赖的是一个道德晴雨表，这是与
with the people that work with you on the show to discern whether or not we're doing good work, where we can improve it, always examine it. But I really try and block out the... Yeah, my question was just what the hell have you been doing? Oh, what have I been doing? That was my only question.
在节目中和你共事的人共同建立的，用来辨别我们是否在做优秀的工作，我们在哪里可以改进，并且时刻审视它。但我真的很努力地屏蔽……对，我的问题只是你到底在干什么？哦，我在干什么？那是我的唯一问题。
Sean's just like, where have you been? He's been advocating for fucking people who don't have a voice, you asshole. And I'm so sorry that he's not on your fucking TikTok. No, I know that. I want, that was a leading question. So you could inform our listeners of what you've been up to. And you're wondering why he's not dancing with his kids
肖恩的意思就是：你到底去哪儿了？他一直在为那些没有发声权力的人仗义执言，你个混蛋！我很抱歉他没有出现在你他妈的TikTok上。不，我知道这个。我希望……那是个引导性问题。好让你可以向我们的听众介绍你最近在忙什么。而你却在纳闷他为什么没有在
on fucking TikTok and dabbing. I mean, what is your fucking problem? Stupid ass. I have been dabbing a few years too late. I love bringing up dabbing because my 13 year old literally, if I mentioned the word dabbing, he looks at me like, don't fucking say another word.
他妈的TikTok上跟孩子们一起跳舞、做Dab动作？我是说，你他妈的有什么毛病？大笨蛋。我确实在晚了好几年之后才开始做Dab动作。我喜欢提起Dab动作，因为我13岁的儿子 literalmente，如果我提到“Dab”这个词，他看着我的眼神就像是在说：别他妈再多说一个字了。
Why are you talking? Let's ask Sean's three minute question in 30 seconds. What have you been doing? And if it's been raising children and prepping another movie, let's hear about that, please. Good question, Jason. I have been raising children. Oh, it's okay when Jason asks.
你为什么在说话？让我们在30秒内问完肖恩那个三分钟的问题吧。你到底在干什么？如果这包括养育孩子和筹备另一部电影，请跟我们讲讲，谢谢。好问题，杰森。我一直在养育孩子。哦，杰森问的时候就行。
Yeah, cause I did it in about 10 seconds. Hey, Will, Will, can we start, I know you love hockey, guys have like a two minute penalty box thing. Maybe start implementing that for 20 seconds, let's say. I like that. Okay, so just know that's dangling there, hey. Will Arnett, do you still play hot?
对，因为我大概10秒钟就问完了。嘿，威尔，威尔，我们可以开始……我知道你喜欢曲棍球，你们有个什么两分钟禁闭室的规则吧。也许可以考虑对（我）实施个20秒的，比方说。我喜欢这个。好吧，那就记住它还悬在那儿，嘿。威尔·阿奈特，你还打曲棍……
Are you still, is it something that you will still go out and play? No, the last time I went out and actually played, I was so, I left the rink, I remember, with my bag and kind of smiling at some, just pick up and I left like, yeah, also great. And I went home and I iced my legs for 24 hours. And I know I didn't want anybody to know.
你还在打吗？那是你现在还会出去打的运动吗？不，我最后一次出去真正打球的时候，我太……我离开冰场时，我记得，带着我的包，还对某些人笑笑，就是随兴比赛，然后我离开的时候心想：嗯，也很棒。然后我回家冰敷了双腿24小时。我知道我不想让任何人知道。
And I was like, fuck, I'm done. Right, done. You still have that nice high shelf ass though on you, don't you? Well, no, yeah. Does he have sort of a shelf? Yeah, real skater ass. That's nice.
当时我就想：操，我完蛋了。没错，完蛋了。你身上仍然保留着那个漂亮的、高翘的屁股吧，对吗？嗯，没有，对。他算是有个翘臀吗？对，真正的滑冰运动员屁股。挺不错的。
No, I've got, what we referred to in the NH, I got a pro dumper, John. And John, do you play hockey? I know you're a soccer guy. I'm a big soccer guy too. I did not play hockey. And unfortunately, my shelf collapsed about three years ago, my shelf ass, yeah.
不，我拥有的是……我们在NH（国家冰球联盟）里称之为“职业级大屁股”，乔恩。乔恩，你打曲棍球吗？我知道你是踢足球的。我也是个超级足球迷。我没打过曲棍球。不幸的是，我的翘臀大约在三年前塌陷了，我的翘臀，是的。
Same thing happened at Jason, where actually we just opened an investigation into the guy who stole his ass because we're trying to find it. Jason, I don't know if this happened to you, but my ass was there one day and then gone the next, almost like if you've ever seen an ice flow calf, like it was there and it was hanging on a threat.
杰森身上也发生了同样的事，事实上我们刚刚对那个偷走他屁股的家伙展开了调查，因为我们正试图把它找回来。杰森，我不知道这有没有发生在你身上，但我的屁股有一天还在，第二天就没了，几乎就像如果你见过冰川断裂脱落一样——它本来还在，而且千钧一发。
And then suddenly the ass began to slowly, and it hit the water and kind of a spectacular splash. And that was- The investigation was probably less horrific than mine because I didn't find out mine had dropped until I saw it on national television, going away there on Laura Lenny, poor thing. Oh no, that's not true.
然后突然间，屁股开始慢慢地……然后它掉进水里，溅起了一朵壮观的水花。那次……这项调查可能比我的没那么可怕，因为我直到在全国电视上看到它，在劳拉·琳妮（Laura Lenny）旁边晃荡时，才发现自己的屁股已经下垂了，真可怜。哦不，那不是真的。
Well, look, there's a little bit of a hang there. There's a crease that I didn't use to have at the bottom of my right buttock. That scene, quite honestly, I remember turning to my wife and saying, that's gotta be stunt cheeks, because that can't be Bateman. I know Bateman isn't that robust.
好吧，看，那里确实有点下垂。我右边臀部底部有一个以前没有的褶皱。老实说，那一幕，我记得我转向妻子说：“那一定是替身屁股，因为那绝不可能是贝特曼。”我知道贝特曼没有那么健壮。
You're in a stunt cheeks. That's a stage name. Yeah, that's the name I dance under. As we get into sports and stuff, and I mentioned soccer, so I know that you did play soccer, you played soccer in college. What I like to refer to as football.
你用的是替身屁股。那是艺名。对，那是我跳舞时用的名字。既然我们聊到了体育之类的，我提到了足球，所以我知道你确实踢过足球，你在大学里踢过足球。我喜欢称之为“英式足球”（Football）。
The beautiful game. You're talking about the beautiful game. I'm a fucking nut for it. The last 10 years I've just gone crazy. Do you watch a lot? I watch quite, mostly Premier League. I don't watch much of it. I'm not so nuts that it's like,
这项美丽的运动。你说的就是这项美丽的运动。我简直为它疯狂着迷。过去10年我简直快疯了。你看很多比赛吗？我看了相当多，主要看英超。我其实看的不算多。我还没疯狂到那种程度，像是：
Siri, ah, La Liga. But I'll watch Premier League. I'll follow Liverpool. Same. I'm a big Liverpool supporter. Take it easy. Yes. He's calm now.
“Siri，啊，西甲联赛。”但我会看英超。我会关注利物浦。一样。我是利物浦的死忠粉。冷静点。对。他现在冷静下来了。
Yeah, no, it's so good. Okay, what about kids? I see a sippy cup in the background. Is that yours or a child's? That's actually, I think it's a candle that my wife put in here. She likes to make things look nice in my office because she knows that I don't look nice in my office.
对，不，太棒了。好吧，那孩子呢？我看到背景里有一个学饮杯。那是你的还是孩子的？那其实……我想那是我妻子放在这里的蜡烛。她喜欢让我的办公室看起来好看一些，因为她知道我在办公室里看起来不好看。
It's a nice contrast. But my children, my son just got his driver's license. Wow. He's seven. What? So good. He just turned 17. My daughter is gonna be 16.
这是一个很好的对比。但我的孩子们，我儿子刚刚拿到驾照。哇。他七岁。什么？太厉害了。他刚满17岁。我女儿快16岁了。
So we're sort of enjoying our last couple of years. Wait, are you doing the college tours and stuff like that? We're getting ready to do that. We're gonna do it pandemic style. So it's a lot of, you know, I don't know how that's gonna fly more. I imagine private. Listen.
所以我们算是正在享受最后这几年。等等，你们在做大学校园参观之类的吗？我们正准备这么做。我们打算以大流行风格来进行。所以会有很多，你知道的，我不知道这以后会怎么样。我猜是私人……听着。
Why are you just backwards? I just took my, are almost 13 year old to his first, he just went to his first day of middle school and I can tell you that was rough watching my baby go into the world like a quasi adult. It was a very scary moment. Middle school is sixth grade, seventh grade, eighth grade. Yeah, yes.
你怎么这么倒退？我刚带我快13岁的儿子去上……他刚去上初中的第一天，我可以说，看着我的宝贝像一个准成年人一样步入社会，那种感觉太难受了。那是一个非常吓人的时刻。初中是六年级、七年级、八年级。对，是的。
So he was going to seventh grade and it was, I was so scary. It changes quickly. So I'll give you a little, this is a little story of how like, and I noticed it. Cause when they're teenagers, they really become people quickly.
所以他要上七年级了，那真是……我太害怕了。变化太快了。所以我给你们讲个小故事，这是一个关于……我是怎么注意到这一点的。因为当他们是青少年时，他们真的会迅速转变成独立的人。
My daughter, when she used to get sick and you need an antibiotic, you remember you'd go to the pharmacy and they don't give you pills. They can't swallow pills. So they would make those concoctions like banana, chocolate, erythromycin, you know, and you'd shake it up and...
我女儿以前生病需要吃抗生素时，你还记得你会去药房，他们不给你药丸。他们吞不下药丸。所以他们会调制那些混合药剂，比如香蕉味、巧克力味、红霉素，你知道的，然后你把它摇匀……
I have one of those every morning. Oh, they're delicious. Yeah. So I would give it to her and she used to be, she would take it like this. Stink face. And it would take 45 minutes.
我每天早晨都喝一杯。哦，它们可好喝了。对。所以我以前给她喂药，她过去常常是这样。一脸嫌弃。而且要花45分钟。
Yeah. To get her to do one. So about six months ago, she has strep. So we get her, or what's this? She had a terrible cold and I got her Nyquil.
才能让她吃完。所以大约六个月前，她得了链球菌感染。所以我们给她……或者这是什么？她得了可怕的感冒，我给她买了我奎尔（Nyquil）。
That's what it was. So I give her the Nyquil. I pour it, I hand it to her. She does this. It's like a shot. Right. And I go, oh, you're drinking now. Yeah.
就是那个。所以我把我奎尔倒出来，递给她。她就这样。就像喝烈酒一样。对。然后我说：“哦，你现在开始喝酒了。”对。
So that's what I'm saying. Like, you learn, life comes at you fast. I had a couple more questions, John, just cause I find you interesting. Yes, Sean. Who, I've always wondered, because when you've done your show for so long. Please ask him his favorite color.
所以这就是我想说的。你看，生活向你袭来得太快了。我还有几个问题，乔恩，只是因为我觉得你很有趣。是的，肖恩。谁……我一直想知道，因为你主持你的节目这么长时间。请问他最喜欢的颜色是什么。
Please ask him his favorite color. When you've done your show, I look at you and I go, what is your favorite color? I wonder what that guy's favorite color is. No, I wonder how, because I think millions of people looked at you as the guy who had the answers.
请问他最喜欢的颜色是什么。当你做你的节目时，看着你，我就会想：你最喜欢的颜色是什么？我很想知道那个家伙最喜欢的颜色是什么。不，我想知道，因为我认为数以百万计的人把你当作那个拥有答案的人。
You were such a leader, right? In your lane. And so who did you admire? Who do you admire now? Who do you look up to kind of in your same field? Who's a game changer in world issues that you maybe commiserate with? Or who is that person or people?
你真是一位领军人物，对吧？在你的领域里。那么你崇拜谁？你现在崇拜谁？在你的同行中，你比较敬仰谁？在世界问题上，有没有哪个改变游戏规则的人是你可能会产生共鸣的？或者那个或那些人是谁？
Fareed Zakaria. Jesus. I look to anyone on the MSNBC weekend slate. Okay, very good, very good. I don't, and I, you know, it's interesting. I think, where are you getting your info? Well, like, I think like most people, I'm getting it through a fucking fire hose up my ass
法里德·扎卡里亚。天哪。我会关注MSNBC周末时段的任何人。好吧，非常好，非常好。我没有，而且我，你知道，这很有趣。我在想，你的信息是从哪儿来的？嗯，就像大多数人一样，我觉得我是通过一根塞进我屁股里的他妈的消防水管来获取信息的。
like everybody else. I mean, it's, this world is nothing but info. It brings up a good point, Jason. You are convinced that there is a secret source of info out there that people have access to, because he asks people a lot of stuff. There's a funnel of information that the media outlets have access to,
就像其他人一样。我的意思是，这个世界除了信息什么都没有。这提出了一个很好的观点，杰森。你确信外面有一个人们可以接触到的秘密信息源，因为他经常问人们各种事情。有一个媒体机构可以接触到的信息漏斗，
and then the fire hose. Yes, and so I'm assuming that those in privileged places like yourself might still have contacts, leads, sources that you might be warm, yeah. I do, I do. There's something called, I have it, Apple News. Oh God.
然后是消防水管。是的，所以我假设像你这样处于优越地位的人可能仍然有联系人、线索、消息来源，你可能会热络一些，是的。我有，我有的。有一个东西叫，我有，苹果新闻。哦，天哪。
And what I'll do is I'll click on it, and then a variety of stories will come up, places that I follow. Do you do the thing that I found myself doing recently, which is when I'm about to like having a moment like, oh, I'm gonna check the news, or I'm gonna check Twitter and stuff. And I now have this moment where I go,
然后我会做的就是点击它，接着就会出现各种各样的故事，都是我关注的地方。你有没有做过我最近发现自己会做的事，那就是当我正准备像——有那么一刻，哦，我要去看看新闻，或者我要去看看推特之类的。我现在会有这样一个时刻，我会去想：
how frustrated do I wanna be right now? Do I wanna ruin my mood, you know? You know, and that leads to this issue we started talking about, which is, you know, how do you balance, certainly you, how did you balance, and how do you continue to balance, how much you allow yourself to be exposed to, weighed against your ability to affect change?
我现在到底想有多沮丧？我想毁了我的心情吗，你知道吗？你知道，这引出了我们开始讨论的问题，也就是，你知道，你是如何平衡的，当然是你，你是如何平衡的，以及你如何继续平衡，你让自己接触多少信息，与你影响改变的能力之间的关系？
When you had the Daily Show, I would imagine you could risk exposing yourself to something that might upset you because you had an outlet for that, and you could possibly affect change at five o'clock, or whenever you guys would start to, because you could share that information to the masses, and maybe some change would come.
当你主持《每日秀》时，我想你可以冒险让自己接触一些可能会让你心烦的事物，因为你有这样一个宣泄的渠道，而且你可能能够在五点钟左右，或者你们开始准备的时候产生影响，因为你可以将这些信息分享给大众，也许就会带来一些改变。
I don't think that was, though, it's not purposeful like that, you know? I think, you know, the amount of change you can affect is really, I have one kind of monkey trick, and that is that you can turn, if you have the ability to conduct light, in other words, like if what you do will attract attention, then the only real trick you have is,
不过我不认为那是——它不是那种有目的性的，你知道吗？我认为，你知道，你能带来的改变其实是——我有一种类似杂耍的把戏，那就是你可以转移——如果你有引导光线的能力，换句话说，就像你做的事会吸引注意力一样，那么你唯一真正的把戏就是：
you can deflect that light or attention onto something you think is interesting, worthwhile, funny, whatever. But what I learned about all this is, I think sometimes we confuse cultural power with power, and having a mouthpiece with being an effective agent of change, and the truth is that change takes place
你可以将这种光线或注意力转移到你认为有趣、有价值、搞笑或任何你觉得好的事情上。但我从这一切中了解到的是，我认为有时我们把文化权力和权力混为一谈了，把拥有一个发声筒和成为一个有效的变革推动者混为一谈了，而事实是，改变是通过共同努力，
incrementally over time through the concerted, it's manual labor. It's true, but there is now more than ever a pressure that is generated through media, through social, but it's not, so I used to, I was raised on the ethos of the emperor's new clothes, right? That was the fable, you know, the emperor, he says he's got a beautiful new coat,
随着时间推移逐步发生的，这是体力活。确实如此，但现在比以往任何时候都更有压力，这种压力是通过媒体、通过社交网络产生的——但它不是，所以我以前——我是伴随着《皇帝的新衣》的乙托斯（精神）长大的，对吧？那是那个寓言，你知道的，皇帝说他有一件漂亮的新外套，
and he walks on the street and the little boy says, oh, he's naked, and that breaks the spell. And by pointing out absurdity or hypocrisy, the spell is broken. And that was kind of the way that I was raised, that I thought the world worked. What I didn't realize is, you know, that you don't ever follow the story,
他走上街头，小男孩说，哦，他光着身子呢，这就打破了魔咒。通过指出荒谬或虚伪，魔咒就被打破了。这有点像我被抚养长大、认为世界运转的方式。我没有意识到的是，你知道，你从来不会去追踪这个故事，
and how it is now is, he's not wearing any clothes, and then the crowd turns, and rather than laughing, they turn and go, you're running a pedophile ring, and you're fake news, and then they cast the boy out, and then everybody takes off their clothes, and they all just pretend that that's how that it was. So my point about that is, shining a light on things can be weighted out.
而现在的情况是，他什么也没穿，然后人群转过头来，他们不仅没有笑，反而转身说，你在搞一个恋童癖团伙，你是假新闻，接着他们把小男孩赶了出去，然后所有人都脱掉衣服，大家就都假装事情本该如此。所以我对此的观点是，把聚光灯照在某些事情上是可以被消解掉的。
I think what those in power have realized is, the attention span, especially in a modern media environment, has the circadian rhythms of Twitter, in that it's ephemeral, it's ubiquitous, and it's meaningless. And so if you're going to bring shame, you better be ready to bring it over time, and it has to be concerted.
我认为掌权者已经意识到，注意力持续时间，尤其是在现代媒体环境中，有着推特那般的昼夜节律，即它是短暂的、无处不在的、毫无意义的。所以如果你想带来羞辱，你最好准备好随着时间持续不断地带来它，而且必须是齐心协力的。
So I always view what we do as, these people that are bringing the real effort, you know, let's just amplify them in a way that makes it clear that we're not going to go away, because unless they feel that there's consequence to their shame, nothing gets done, and the only way they'll feel like there's consequence to their shame is if the shame will be unceasing.
所以我总是把我们所做的事情看作是——那些真正付出努力的人，你知道的，让我们以一种明确表明我们不会离开的方式来放大他们的声音，因为除非他们觉得他们的耻辱会带来后果，否则什么也做不成，而他们觉得耻辱会有后果的唯一方法，就是这种耻辱将是连绵不绝的。
We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. It occurs to me that potentially there was a time, you know, there's that stat that technology increases 30 times, every 10 years it's 30 times greater than the previous 10 years, and that's astonishing. And I think that we always, you know, when we had the Jetsons, we always thought like,
我们马上回来。好了，回到节目中。我突然想到，可能曾几何时，你知道，有这样一个统计数据，科技每10年增长30倍，每10年都比前10年强大30倍，这太惊人了。而且我认为我们总是，你知道的，当我们有《杰森一家》时，我们总是认为：
this is what the future is going to be, it's all going to be about technology. And truthfully, I think the thing that nobody ever saw was, the thing that was going to be the most important thing was information, and the way that it's delivered, and the volume, the sheer volume of it, and the way that it can be really wielded as a weapon and be weaponized in a way that we couldn't imagine.
这就是未来的样子，一切都将与科技有关。老实说，我认为从来没有人预料到的一点是，最重要的事情将是信息，以及它的传递方式、它的体量，纯粹的体量，以及它如何能真正被作为一种武器挥舞，并以我们无法想象的方式被武器化。
We thought that the, for instance, the Nazis had manipulated information to a way that we couldn't fucking believe, and that was, you know, almost 100 years ago. Now we have people who have perfected it, and have found channels to, you know, vessels to do that in ways that are so incredibly harmful. But don't you think that we should have known that?
我们曾认为，例如，纳粹对信息的操纵达到了我们他妈的难以置信的程度，而那已经是将近100年前的事了。现在我们有些人已经把这门技术臻于完美，并找到了渠道，你知道，找到了工具，以极其有害的方式做到这一点。但难道你不觉得我们本该知道这一点的吗？
Because it's- Of course we should have. The one thing that is consistent in people is that whatever progress we make will be perverted, that everything has that dual, you know, so when you think about the algorithm, right, so artificial intelligence, we're working to create, you know, this kind of intelligence
因为它是——我们当然应该知道。人类身上唯一不变的一点是，无论我们取得什么进步，都会被扭曲，每件事都有这种两面性，所以，当你想到算法时，对吧，也就是人工智能，我们正在努力创造，你知道，这种智慧，
that is far beyond the capacity that what we could do. And we will use it to advance the cause of longevity and the health and welfare of all the people. And what have we decided to use it for? A way to keep you watching YouTube longer. Like, that's what we use the app. Everything that we do gets perverted because, you know, if I may quote MC Hammer.
其能力远远超出了我们所能做到的。我们将用它来推进长寿事业以及全人类的健康和福祉。而我们决定用它来做什么？用它来让你在YouTube上多看一会儿视频。没错，这就是我们使用这款应用的目的。我们所做的一切都被扭曲了，因为，如果我可以引用MC·哈默的话。
Yeah, please. Sean does it all the time. It was daily. Fucking time. He went, he was on somewhere, and I can't remember where it was, but he said, you cannot consider the measure of something without considering the measure.
行，请吧。肖恩总是这么说。这简直是日常。他妈的天天如此。他去过，他在某个地方说过，我不记得是在哪儿了，但他说过，如果不考虑尺度，你就无法衡量某事物的尺度。
And the point is like, all these things are tools, but they are tools that are wielded by people. And people are flawed and are always looking for advantage. So, you know, think about every bit of progress we've ever made through science, let's say, like whether it's chemical or biological or sonic or anything, any progress we make somewhere someone has tried to weaponize it.
关键在于，所有这些东西都是工具，但它们是由人来挥舞的工具。而人是有缺陷的，总是想方设法谋取利益。所以，你知道，想想我们通过科学取得的每一次进步，比方说，无论是化学、生物、声学还是别的什么，我们取得的任何进步，某处都会有人试图将其武器化。
Yes. And that's, we always have to take that into account. Everything that we get, what's better than the combustion engine to create progress and to lift people out of poverty and what creates global warming? Like, everything, it's all a fucking balance. And we just have to try and do it without falling over.
是的。这就是——我们必须时刻把这一点考虑进去。我们得到的每一样东西，有什么比内燃机更能创造进步、将人们从贫困中解救出来的呢？然而又是什么造成了全球变暖？就像每件事一样，这全他妈是个平衡。我们只是必须努力做到这一点，而不会翻车。
The wheel led to, you know, car deaths. Think about it that way, okay? So. Where are you going to flush all the, you know so much that is so unsettling. Where do you go to flush all that out? Is it the bottom of a bong or are you watching a nice cartoon?
车轮导致了，你知道的，车祸。换个角度想想，好吧？所以。你要把所有这些——你知道的那么多让人心神不宁的事——都倾倒到哪里去？你是去吸个大麻烟斗，还是去看个好看的动画片？
Or do you meditate? What do you, what do you, what do you do? I play, I try and play the drums. That's it. I am not musical. I took it up when I left the show and I always wanted to interact with music and I'm terrible at it.
还是去冥想？你，你，你到底做什么？我玩——我尽量打架子鼓。就这样。我一点也不懂音乐。我离开节目后开始学这个，我一直想和音乐互动，而我在这方面烂极了。
So I was going to learn how to play guitar. I don't know if you guys have ever played anything, but like I sat down with a guitar and I was like, oh, this is fucking hard. It hurts my fingers. And it's going to take me three years before I can even just play blackbirds slowly. But I know how to bang on shit.
所以我本来打算学吉他。我不知道你们有没有弹过什么乐器，但当我拿着一把吉他坐下来时，我就想，哦，这他妈太难了。它弄得我手指生疼。而且我要花三年时间才能勉强把《Blackbird》这首歌慢慢弹下来。但我懂得敲敲打打。
Yeah, sure. And so I could interact with music really quickly. But I didn't realize this. As long as it was sticks. No, no, no, with, with sticks, maybe right there. Let's hear a little something, John. I keep, in my office, I have a little pad. Oh, that's right.
对，当然。所以我可以非常快地与音乐互动。但我没有意识到这一点。只要有鼓棒就行？不，不，不，拿着——拿着鼓棒，也许就在那儿。听一听一小段，约翰。我一直，在我的办公室里，我有一个小垫子。哦，对。
Paradiddle, paradiddle, paradiddle, paradiddle. So I bang around all the time, but the thing that's incredible about it is, so it's all about like limb independence and creating these rhythmic connections that didn't exist before. And you can't do them when you first try them, but if you slow them down and you go through it
单击双击，单击双击，单击双击，单击双击。所以我一直敲敲打打，但关于这个最不可思议的事情是，它完全关乎四肢独立，以及建立以前不存在的这种节奏连接。当你刚开始尝试时，你无法做到，但如果你把它们放慢速度，然后有条不紊地、
kind of mechanically and with purpose. You can rewire. Slowly you rewire. And suddenly now you can do it at speed and you're creating connections that never occurred. And you can almost feel the synapses in your brain crap. It's like the opposite of death. And for me, I just like making shit, right?
有目的地进行。你可以重塑。慢慢地，你重塑了大脑。突然之间，你就能加速完成了，你正在建立从未出现过的神经连接。你几乎能感觉到你大脑中的突触在——这就像死亡的对立面。对我来说，我只是喜欢创造东西，对吧？
And that's what gives me a feeling of wellbeing or purpose or anything along those lines. And so discovering that was only five years ago was a real eye-opener. Yeah, you hit, Sean loves that. He likes making his housekeeper turn the channel on direct TV and shit. So he loves.
这就是给我带来幸福感、目标感或任何类似感觉的东西。所以发现这一点——那仅仅是五年前的事——真的是大开眼界。是的，你击中——肖恩最喜欢那个了。他喜欢让他的管家去换Direct TV频道的台之类的东西。所以他很喜欢。
Well, I like the sound of the click. I like the sound of the click. Metronome is the best thing you know. No, but it's like anything what you just described as long as you want it, as long as you want to learn something, as long as you want to expand your hobbies, your brain, your synapses, like you say,
嗯，我喜欢那个点击的声音。我喜欢那个点击的声音。节拍器是你所知道的最好的东西。不，但这就像你刚才描述的任何事情一样，只要你想要，只要你想学点东西，只要你想拓展你的爱好、你的大脑、你的突触，就像你说的，
and you take your time to do it because you want to do it, you will get better at it. John, do you want to direct another movie? Yes, I do. Did you love it? I loved it. Oh, bossing people around in different countries. Oh, I mean, action, cuss.
并且你花时间去做了，因为你想做，你就会做得更好。约翰，你想再导演一部电影吗？是的，我想。你喜欢吗？我喜欢。哦，在不同的国家对别人指手画脚。哦，我的意思是，动作，卡。
I mean, it's just the dictatorial force that flows through your cut again. That sweater, no, no, put him in that sweater. No, put him in that sweater. I love it. Speaking of which, did you wear a fancy director outfit on your set days? No way.
我的意思是，那种专断的力量流淌过你的——再剪一次。那件毛衣，不，不，让他穿那件毛衣。不，让他穿那件毛衣。我太喜欢了。说到这儿，你在片场拍戏时穿过什么时髦的导演服装吗？绝不。
Do you think Egyptian silk is fancy? Not if you're an Egyptian. How do you define it? If you shot in Egypt, it's not fancy. We actually went there. Yeah, yeah. I actually went to, we shot in Jordan and a friend of mine hosted a show in Cairo
你觉得埃及丝绸很时髦吗？如果你是个埃及人的话，就不时髦。你怎么定义它？如果你在埃及拍摄，它就不时髦。我们实际上去过那里。对，对。我其实去过——我们在约旦拍摄，我的一个朋友在开罗主持一个节目，
right during the middle of the revolution and he invited me to come on. And I went to Cairo like a week before they overthrew Mohammed Borsi. Oh, God. It was fucking chaos. Wow, wow. Is it safe to go there anymore?
就在革命正中间的时候，他邀请我去参加。我在穆罕默德·穆尔西被推翻前大约一个星期去了开罗。哦，天哪。那他妈简直是一片混乱。哇，哇。去那里还安全吗？
Can we go to Egypt yet or no? Oh, yeah. No, it was safe then too. I mean, it wasn't. It wasn't fun. He means him and Scotty. They're bags of acting. We want to go.
我们现在还能去埃及吗，还是不能？哦，会去的。不，那时候也很安全。我是说，它并不——并不好玩。他是指他和斯科蒂。他们是演艺界的卧龙凤雏。我们想去。
We want to see where the aliens built those pyramids. Yes. We went inside them and it's very weird. It's like when you ever visit where they built the Star Wars sets, it's all hollow behind it. The whole thing. Don't tell us, don't tell us on that.
我们想去看看外星人建造那些金字塔的地方。是的。我们走进了金字塔内部，感觉非常诡异。就像你参观《星球大战》布景的地方一样，后面全都是空的。整座建筑都是。别告诉我们，别跟我们说这个。
Oh, it's just a bunch of two by fours. It's not, what do you mean it's not real? I don't believe that it's not real. When you get up close, you go, oh my God, that's just magic marker. They just drew that in. John, I always considered you. You always feel like you were like the senior
哦，那只是一堆两乘四规格的木方。它不是——什么叫它不是真的？我不相信它不是假的。当你走近一看，你会想，哦天哪，那只是记号笔。他们只是画上去的。约翰，我一直视你为——在喜剧界，你总给我们一种学长、
when we were freshmen in comedy. And I still feel that way. And I look up to you in that way. And who, you're a sort of your class, your grade, your contemporaries. We had, well, obviously Colbert, those close good buddy of yours and you were instrumental in getting a show off the ground.
就像我们刚上喜剧大学时大四学长的感觉。我至今仍有这种感觉。我在那方面很敬仰你。那么谁——你那届的、你的同龄人有哪些？我们有——显然，科尔伯特，那是你的好哥们儿，你在帮他的节目开播方面发挥了重要作用。
He came out of the Daily Show onto the Colbert Report. Who else were your contemporaries? Who were the people that you came up with in stand up and in that time in New York when you were doing stand up in the 80s? So that was all like, the class before us had just graduated and moved out to Los Angeles. So my class was, down in the comedy cellar
他从《每日秀》走出来，主持了《科尔伯特报告》。还有谁是你的同龄人？在80年代你在纽约做单口喜剧时，和你同期的单口喜剧演员都有谁？所以那全都是——在我们之前的那届刚刚毕业并搬去了洛杉矶。所以我的那届，是在喜剧地窖（Comedy Cellar）里
was Colin Quinn, Ray Romano, Chappelle. Rock and Sandler were more comic strip guys, but they would come downtown. But that was the same sort of era. Leary, Laura Keilinger, that was kind of the David Tell. What a great time for comedy. What an incredible, like the golden era of stand up in a way. And the best part was the money.
有柯林·奎恩、雷·罗马诺、查佩尔。罗克和桑德勒更像是连环漫画风格的喜剧演员，但他们也会去市中心。不过那差不多是同一个时代。利里、劳拉·凯林格，那有点像戴夫·泰尔的风格。多棒的喜剧时代啊。在某种程度上，这简直是单口喜剧的黄金时代。最棒的部分是能赚到钱。
Yeah, sure, of course. I mean, so much. You know, you're working five nights a week for a play to hummus and a couple of falafels. That was rock. But I will say you do. We loved it. But so you guys are there.
对，没错，当然。我的意思是，有那么多。你知道的，你一周工作五个晚上，换来的却是一点鹰嘴豆泥和几个法拉afel。那就是摇滚。但我得说，你是的。我们太喜欢了。所以你们当时在那儿。
You're doing, yeah, you're going down to the comedy cellar. You're making five bucks or whatever. But back then too, the comedy cellar wasn't the comedy cellar. It was, it did one show a night, except on weekends they would do two shows a night. But now you go down there on a Tuesday and they're gonna do four shows and the houses are packed. And I used to go on every night.
你们在，对，你们会去喜剧地窖（Comedy Cellar）。你们只能赚五块钱或者别的什么。但在那个时候，喜剧地窖可不是现在的喜剧地窖。它以前一晚只演一场，除了周末一晚演两场。但现在你周二去那里，他们要演四场，而且座无虚席。我以前每天晚上都会上台。
I worked, I was a day bartender at a Mexican restaurant up the block, which is by the way, just, I don't want to romanticize the day bartending at a Mexican restaurant. Unbleeker, unbleeker? That's on McDougall, Pancitos. Oh. Can I tell you a great story about working at Pancitos?
我干过，我曾是街上一家墨西哥餐厅的白天酒保，顺便说一句，我可不想把在墨西哥餐厅当白天酒保这事浪漫化。在布里克街，布里克街？那是麦克杜格尔街的Pancitos餐厅。哦。我能跟你讲一个在Pancitos工作的精彩故事吗？
So being a day bartender in a Mexican restaurant, you are basically just like a laborer that's preparing margaritas and fruit for the night bartender to come in and fucking clean up. And so you make, nobody tips you out because there's nobody there, but there was this guy Bob who ran the place, he owned it. I left Pancitos probably in 1988, 1989,
所以在墨西哥餐厅当白天酒保，你基本上就像个体力劳动者，负责调调制备玛格丽特酒和水果，好让晚上的酒保来接班然后他妈的好好清理一番。所以你赚的，根本没人给你小费，因为压根没人来。但那里有个叫鲍勃的家伙，他是经营这个地方的，他是老板。我大概在1988年或1989年离开Pancitos的，
and finally was making the $15 a night at the comedy cellar and decided I'm just gonna focus on that. Maybe 25 years later, I'm walking down a village street. Now this is after the success of the Daily Show and I'm the big man walking through the old neighborhood pointing sights out that I had my first falafel sandwich with it, I see the guy who owned Pancitos walking towards me.
最后终于在喜剧地窖赚到了每晚15美元，然后决定我得专心搞这个了。大概25年后，我走在村子的一条街上。这已经是在《每日秀》成功之后了，我成了个大人物，走在旧社区里，指着我第一次吃法拉afel三明治的那些地方，我看到Pancitos的老板正朝我走来。
It's been 25 years as he gets closer to me, he just goes, John, and just keeps. Nice. Just fucking, dude, that is- John. That at first of all is so New York, right? Like, who gives a, yeah, you're the big man, but also like, yeah, you're John, so how's it going?
已经过去25年了，当他越走越近时，他只是说：“约翰。”然后就继续走。太棒了。就他妈的，老兄，那是——约翰。首先这太纽约了吧，对吧？就像，谁他妈在乎，对啊，你现在是大人物了，但同时也是，好吧，你就是约翰，最近怎么样？
That's right, by the way, I need you to pick up a shift. Yeah, exactly. So I was walking down 7th Avenue a few years ago, walking by this bar that will remain McManus at the corner of 19th and 7th. Sure, McManus. And I drank there every night for five. I claimed that I could have gotten a law school
没错，顺便说一句，我需要你来顶个班。对，完全如此。所以几年前我正走在第七大道上，走过一家将保持匿名的酒吧——位于第19街和第七大道拐角的麦克马纳斯（McManus）。没错，麦克马纳斯。我在那里没日没夜地喝了五年。我敢说，
with the time and money I spent in there, I could have easily. So anyway, so I'm walking with my dad and those drinking years are far behind me at that point and I'm walking along and as we're coming, we're moving from 20th Street right on 7th Avenue and just getting closer, I say this place, this is the place McManus where I spend every night
凭我在里面耗费的时间和金钱，我完全可以去读法学院了。所以无论如何，我和我爸爸一起走着，那些酗酒的岁月当时已经远远抛在脑后了，我一边走着，当我们从第20街正沿着第七大道走来，越来越近的时候，我说这个地方，就是这里，麦克马纳斯，我在这里度过了每一个夜晚，
for about five, seven years, just six nights a week, hammered, and I see one of the bartenders standing outside. This guy, Mike, and he's smoking a cigarette and I go, yeah, God, every night for five, six years, I run around and I look up and I see Mike and I go, isn't that right, Mike? And he goes, you got it, Will. We never broke stride.
大概持续了五七年吧，一周六天，烂醉如泥，然后我看到一个酒保正站在外面。这家伙叫迈克，他正在抽烟，我说，天哪，每个夜晚，持续了五六年，我跑过去抬头看着迈克，我说：“对吧，迈克？”他说：“你说得对，威尔。”我们连脚步都没停一下。
I never stopped to say hi. We just kept walking and fucking, it was incredible. Yeah, great. You could have had the best production, you could never time that out that well. Hey, John, so your kids on the doorstep of going to college and you being an empty nester have you and the Mrs. started the plans for empty nesting,
我甚至没停下来打个招呼。我们只是继续走，他妈的，太不可思议了。是的，太棒了。你就算有最好的制作团队，也绝对无法把时间掐得这么准。嘿，约翰，你的孩子们马上就要上大学了，而你将成为空巢老人，你和太太开始规划空巢生活了吗，
how you're gonna distract yourself from the sadness or is it gonna be all euphoric? Well, I mean, for us, it's just waiting for you, Schmucks, to put out more TV. We need to head just for you. We sit at home and we just wait for it. Yeah, when is that fucking? Is there a new episode of Ozark?
你们打算怎么转移对这种伤感的注意力，还是说这会是一场彻头彻尾的狂欢？好吧，我的意思是，对我们来说，只是在等你们这些混蛋多拍点电视节目。我们只为你们而驻足。我们坐在家里，就等着看呢。对，那部该死的什么时候出？Ozark（黑钱胜地）有新的一集吗？
Can we do anything here? Yeah, when's that? Ozark coming out. I think January, that's what I'm, that's what I'm thinking. Hurry it up. Yeah. We're making it right now. And spin it off.
我们在这儿能做点啥吗？对，那个什么时候播？《黑钱胜地》什么时候上映。我想是明年一月，我是这么想的。快点吧。对。我们现在正在制作。还有衍生剧。
We're almost done. Because I need content. So it's just gonna be TV, that's what you're telling me. That's what's gonna be the time for you. We have a farm and it's like a rescue farm for cows and pigs and goats and sheep and we work with, we really, I lived in the city for so many years and we moved out, I don't know, five, six years ago
我们快完成了。因为我需要内容。所以这全都是关于看电视的，这就是你要告诉我的。这就是你的消遣时间。我们有个农场，它有点像是个专门收容牛、猪、山羊和绵羊的救援农场，我们跟它们一起工作，我真的——我在城里住了好多年，然后我们搬出去了，大概五六年前吧，
and just quality of life, man. It's good for you. I spent so many years looking through the tube of the, the paper towel holder. The cardboard table holder doing the daily show, like so focused. And I was so worried about like, oh my God, what am I gonna do when I don't have that anymore?
生活质量简直绝了，老兄。这对你有好处。我花了太多年的时间透过纸巾卷的圆筒在看世界。
And then when I took it out, I was like, oh. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, so you guys have been working in the whole world. Yeah. I've always been working in the, and so. How old were you when you started the Daily Show? How old were you?
然后当我把它拿出来时，我就想，噢。对。噢，所以你们一直在全世界各地工作。对。我一直都在从事……所以。你开始主持《每日秀》时几岁？你几岁？
Oh God, I was already like 35. I started, the Daily Show was my, if this doesn't work out, Pancitos is looking for another Dave Arden. Right, right, right. It was one of those. Right. Hey, Jen.
噢天哪，我当时已经35岁左右了。我开始做《每日秀》的时候，我的想法是，如果这个行不通，Pancitos还在招别的白天酒保呢。对，对，对。就是那种情况。对。嘿，詹。
Hey, Jen. Hey, Jen. Hey, Jen. Great question. What is everybody else's? You guys have plans, like Sean, what's your plan, your 10-year plan? Work my balls off.
嘿，詹。嘿，詹。嘿，詹。问得好。其他人的呢？你们有什么计划吗，比如肖恩，你的计划是什么，你的十年规划？拼死拼活地工作。
That's it? I think I'm gonna be done at 60, between 1665, I'm really gonna be done. Yeah, but then what? Like what are you gonna do? Are you gonna stay in LA or are you gonna? I don't know. What is that?
就这样？我想我会在60岁时收手，在60到65岁之间，我真的会金盆洗手。对，但接下来呢？那你打算做什么？你要留在洛杉矶还是打算？我不知道。那是什么？
I gotta tell you, with your skin, Sean, I keep going. Look at him. It's beautiful. It is beautiful. Thanks, thanks. I keep going. I don't see the sun.
我得告诉你，就凭你的皮肤，肖恩，我真得说。看看他。太棒了。真的很棒。谢谢，谢谢。我继续保持。我见不到太阳。
John, we've taken up way too much of your time. We didn't even get to, if you had any shit stories, because Colbert was on here and he told a 40-minute shit story about Conan, which was, sounds like it was very true. But we've taken up way too much of your time. We'll leave you on that up note.
约翰，我们占用了你太多时间了。我们甚至还没聊到你有没有什么糗事呢，因为科尔伯特之前来过这儿，他讲了一个关于柯南的40分钟的糗事，听起来非常真实。但我们已经占用了你太多时间了。我们就以这个积极的基调结束吧。
Yeah. Beauty. John Stewart, man, you're a fucking legend. It's a pleasure to see you guys. Lots of love to you. I've enjoyed this very much, and thank you for making it easy and simple and lovely. You've done the same for us
好的。太棒了。约翰·斯图尔特，老兄，你他妈真是个传奇。很高兴见到你们。向你们致以满满的爱。我很享受这一切，谢谢你们让这一切变得轻松、简单而美好。你们对我们也一样，
any time we were on your show, sir. Thank you so, so much for this. Rob Cordury did the same for me when I was on your show. Yeah. By the way, Rob wasn't even, I mean, we went through so many people just to see who would do it.
每当我们上你的节目时，先生。非常非常感谢你们。罗伯·柯德瑞当我上你的节目时也为我做过同样的事。对。顺便说一句，罗伯当时甚至都不是……我的意思是，我们考虑了好多人，只是为了看看谁愿意干。
Obviously. I mean, at that point, Colbert, Oliver, Sam B, I mean, we went through everything. Finally, Cordury was like short straw. I'll just fucking jump in. He was the only one left in the city. There was a skeleton crew, too,
显然。我的意思是，在那个时候，科尔伯特、奥利弗、萨姆·比，我的意思是，我们把所有人都考虑了一遍。最后柯德瑞就像是抽中了短签。我他妈豁出去了。他是城里唯一剩下的人了。当时人手也非常紧缺，
if I remember correctly. I remember the quote was exactly this, I'll take the hit. That's fair enough. Thank you, man. Lots of love to you. Great to talk to you guys. Thank you, John.
如果我没记错的话。我记得当时的原话正是这个：“我来扛这雷。”这倒挺公平的。谢谢你，老兄。向你致以满满的爱。很高兴跟你们聊天。谢谢你，约翰。
See you soon. Bye-bye. Bye-bye-bye-bye. You did it, Will. You did it. You did it again. That was a good one. You delivered the golden goose right there.
回头见。拜拜。拜拜拜拜。你做到了，威尔。你做到了。你又做到了。这期节目真不错。你刚刚直接抛出了一只金蛋。
That's the man. What's embarrassing is that Jason had asked him a few times, and I guess he had said no. No, that was Ryan Reynolds. Oh, that was Ryan, and then Ryan said yes to me. Do you remember that? He sure did.
这才是真男人。尴尬的是，杰森曾经问过他好几次，我猜他都拒绝了。不，那是瑞恩·雷诺兹。哦，那是瑞恩，然后瑞恩答应了我。你还记得吗？他当然答应了。
He sure did. Boy, you're not holding on to that, Jason. Jason, you asked John Stewart to be on? Do you know how mad Amanda is, by the way, Amanda's mentioned to me, I don't know, let's say a hundred times that Jason got how many kids Ryan has wrong, and she was like, he knows he's got three kids,
他当然答应了。天哪，你到现在还揪着这个不放啊，杰森。杰森，你邀请了约翰·斯图尔特来吗？顺便说一句，你知道阿曼达有多生气吗，阿曼达跟我提过，比方说有一百次吧，关于杰森把瑞恩有几个孩子给记错了，她当时就说：“他明明知道瑞恩有三个孩子，
and we sent a fucking gift, and I can't believe that I'm so mad at Jason for that. So rude. I'm sorry, I don't have fucking Daily Mail on my toolbar, you know? Jesus. Nobody's a friend of yours, too. That's rude.
而我们还送了一份该死的礼物，我简直不敢相信我为了这事儿这么生杰森的气。”太粗鲁了。对不起，我他妈的浏览器工具栏里可没有《每日邮报》，你知道吗？天哪。而且谁也不是你的朋友。这太粗鲁了。
You don't keep up with your friends on Daily Mail. Oh my God, I know, that's true. Jason was also really, I noticed the other day, he said too, I was drinking these waters that Jason has, and I go, I got these, I was drinking Archie Go, and then he said, Well, what are they called?
你都不用《每日邮报》来跟进朋友们的近况。天哪，我懂，确实如此。杰森也真的很……我前几天注意到，他说过，我一直在喝杰森的那种水，然后我说，我买了这个，我当时在喝Archie Go，然后他说，呃，它们叫什么？
What are they called? Lemon Perfect. Lemon Perfect. It's the best drink in the world. Fucking cool it, and we don't need to mention Lemon Perfect, just so you get a free case, that's like $20 worth,
它们叫什么？Lemon Perfect。Lemon Perfect。世界上最好喝的饮料。他妈的闭嘴吧，我们根本不需要提到Lemon Perfect，哪怕是为了让你免费拿一箱，那也就值20多块钱，
like if they want it. I want a whole truck, I want it on a schedule. I give a lot of shit. Lemon Perfect is incredible. So anyway, Jason's drinking Lemon Perfect, and he goes, oh, look at Jason, he actually started to call Jason Bateman recently,
如果他们想要的话。我想要整整一卡车，我要求按时配送。我满嘴跑火车。Lemon Perfect太绝了。不管怎样，杰森在喝Lemon Perfect，然后他说：“哦，看杰森啊，”我最近甚至开始叫杰森·贝特曼“杰森”了，
a couple of times, and he goes, look at Bateman drinking, you got that idea from my dad, and I go, actually, you know what, Archie, I gotta be fair, Jason's one who introduced me to Lemon Perfect, and Jason turns to him and goes, so, would that really shitty look?
叫了好几次，然后他说：“看贝特曼在喝那个，你这主意是从我爸那儿学来的吧。”然后我说：“其实你知道吗，阿奇，我得说句公道话，是杰森把我领进Lemon Perfect的门。”杰森转过身对他说：“所以呢？”带着那种非常欠揍的表情？
Look, and I go, did you just, to my 12 year old, I go, did you just do the thing that we've been doing to each other for 20 years, to my 12 year old? He's like, yeah. Yeah, you mess with the ball, you know what I mean? So, anyway, let's get back to John Stewart.
听着，然后我说：“你刚刚对我的12岁儿子——”我问，“你刚刚把我们之间互怼了20年的那一套，用在了我12岁的儿子身上？”他就像是：“对啊。”没错，你惹到硬茬了，你知道我的意思吧？所以，无论如何，我们言归正传，继续聊约翰·斯图尔特。
John Stewart. This guy, and even if he doesn't know how to spell his first name, I still love him more than most people on the planet. Yeah, that's easy. I just think he's a perfect combo of smart and funny. Yeah.
约翰·斯图尔特。这家伙，就算他不知道怎么拼写自己的名字，我依然比地球上大多数人都更爱他。对，这很简单。我只是觉得他是聪明与幽默的完美结合。对。
Guy, can we edit that out? I think he's married, dude, so, you know, I don't know if you're, my memory of John Stewart also is just of all those, just, I don't know, 10 years in a row of being at the Emmys, and him just winning every, you know, him going to the stage like three times in the night. Yeah, with just a team of the really gifted writers.
老兄，我们能把那段剪掉吗？我觉得他已经结婚了，老兄，所以，你知道的，我不知道你是不是……我对约翰·斯图尔特的记忆也只停留在那些年，连续大概10年去参加艾美奖，然后他一直赢，你知道的，他一晚上三上领奖台。是的，身边只带了一支极具天赋的编剧团队。
It's just, that show stayed so good for so long. It's so good. They could, another 20 years, just as good. I'm sure, I'm sure he could have, and I'm sure he could, if he said today that he wanted, not necessarily the other show, because Trevor Noah is very good, but like if he wanted to do whatever,
那档节目能保持那么高的水准那么长时间，真是太厉害了。太棒了。他们完全可以再做20年，也一样能这么精彩。我确信，我确信他绝对可以，而且我相信，如果他今天说他想要——不一定是原来的那个节目，因为特雷弗·诺亚非常优秀，但如果他想做点别的什么，
and he's doing this Apple show, which I'm excited about. Yeah, I can't wait to see that Apple show. I know. He's so missed. Did he say one that's coming out? No, we can Google it. I think he said end of September, or at least, bye, October.
而且他现在正在做这个苹果（Apple）的节目，我对这个很期待。对，我等不及要看那个苹果的节目了。我知道。大家太想念他了。他说过什么时候上映吗？没有，我们可以谷歌一下。我想他说的是九月底，或者至少十月份之前吧。
Bye. Wow, all right, I guess, bye. Smart. Blast. Smart. Blast. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbaco.
拜。哇，好吧，我想，拜。聪明。精彩。聪明。精彩。SmartLess 节目由迈克尔·格兰特·泰里、罗布·阿姆贾尔和本·巴巴科100%有机纯手工打造。
The next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or by subscribing to Wondry Plus in the Wondry app. Smart. Blast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下一集将在⼀周后发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，或者现在就可以在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上提前收听，也可以通过 Wondry App 订阅 Wondry Plus。聪明。精彩。本期节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。